I do have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p you can call
that number anytime and many people do
call it at very very odd times let's
take a listen to a voicemail that came
in yesterday a mr pacman uh you know dr.
donald trump is now leading in the polls
yes all you have not said nothing of
this arm on your recent programs are
what do you only report the polls when
they show Hillary Clinton with a huge
lead no okay I guess that's the whole
call uh the lead story today was that
Trump is finally winning one of the
latest 39 polls so uh not surprisingly a
question that is not exactly based in
what this program does I don't think we
have missed any reporting when it comes
to the ebbs and flows of polling in this
campaign on the bonus show today Goldman
Sachs has a band their employees from
donating to Donald Trump we will talk
about a really interesting article
suggesting that the next Industrial
Revolution could put millions of people
out of work well yeah I've been saying
that for years and some very very
unusual clown sightings out of
everybody's favorite anti-trans bathroom
policy State North Carolina we will hear
about that story from Rachel on today's
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership is the one way to sign up and
get instant access